we start with some sad news to share
with you this afternoon iconic channel 8
anchor gary waddell has passed away he
worked here at klas for 32 years before
retiring in 2012. gary passed away last
night from a heart attack at st rose
hospital after he was suffering from
complications from covet 19. he was 77
years old now he spent many of his three
decades at the station sitting alongside
paula francis on the evening news gary
covered many of the events and moments
that left lasting impacts here in our
city from the mgm fire in 1980 to the
chemical explosion and brought us
coverage from national events like
traveling to the 1996 democratic
convention in chicago the first
anniversary of 9 11 at ground zero and
following along with first responders in
hurricane katrina in 2005 his name will
forever be remembered as a respected and
iconic journalist in our great city our
general manager lisa halfield said we
have lost a dear family member and our
hearts are heavy today our condolences
to his family and many friends who share
in our grief governor steve cisilek adds
we'll be keeping gary's friends and
family in our thoughts at this time